Alice finishing it up in style with
another crucial Victory but you are
right now winning your first national
title how are you feeling yeah it feels
like really great
um I've like played in this tournament
for this is my first time and to be able
to win this means a lot to me especially
since this tournament was so strong it
is so strong it's so prestigious it just
means like a really a lot for me
especially since like I worked really
hard to end this tournament I looked up
to so many people here and two wind is
just really great tell us about uh last
night you knew that you won the
tournament last night how were the
celebration looking like
um yeah so after I finish my game
yesterday it was pretty quick so I went
back to the hotel and I spent like a
long time watching Chris's game hoping
like she'd make the correct moves
um and you know actually I Was preparing
for this game
um well I was assuming like she would
draw
um but then during that time where I was
prepared sharing I thought then then she
was winning so then I think okay I can
change up the strategy a little bit
because tomorrow would just be a game
and today it was uh like I thought it
was pretty nice that I was able to win
this game and just finish the tournament
off really cleanly speaking of uh
Carissa that's another first for you
that was the first time you defeated her
one of your mentors and Idols in the
junior girls chess tell us about that
feeling accomplishing so many things in
this tournament and this year as a whole
has been amazing for you yeah definitely
um I
like all right I got like my last item
I am not expecting any of this I was
just like um hoping to like just do
decently I guess
um but yeah to be able to just have this
really great performance means a lot to
me it's such like a strong tournament
and it's really motivating for me to be
able to just do so well here and that
motivation goes a long way what are your
plans for the remainder of the year
maybe the beginning of next year are you
starting to think about that GM title or
is that too soon I mean I just got my
own title so like the GM title was
pretty far away but I definitely am
still like aiming to go for that title
um especially like in the next few years
it'll be crucial and
um so I think for the remaining of the
year
um I'm playing in the world team
championship and the US Women's uh I
might play like in a tournament before
the USA wants to warm up and then
there's like an Isles of men uh Grand I
think Swiss franc Swiss I love man yes
so I mean I think I can actually go to
Norm there if I do well
um but you know that's like really like
hard so
um I'm just like again focusing on
improving I think I have like a lot of
time between now and the world team
championship and I'll focus on like
again like improving trying not to uh I
guess like remain where I am and go up
maybe a bit more and that's probably the
healthy way of looking at things I will
give you the opportunity to highlight
maybe the the people that helped you
along the way during this tournament
maybe thank your fans as well tell us a
bit about that yeah I'd like to thank
everybody who helped organize this
tournament and who helped me during this
tournament so first I'd like to thank my
family my coaches
um and just like everybody the same with
chess club for organizing this event I'd
like to thank all the staff here the
commentary team and also as well guys
what did we do
photography and everybody here who's
like helped my opponents were like it's
just like being here playing in this
tournament
um and listening fields and just like
everybody who have organized I'd also
like to think a chess kid who's been
like really great for me from when I
started playing chess to where I am
today and um again some of like my
previous coaches
um Grandmaster gervich who helped me I
think from when I was like seven to ten
and was like really great for my
Improvement
um just like there's so many people I
have to thank for everything that I've
been able to like achieve so far
um and I'm just really happy that I was
able to do this Alice big
congratulations guys any questions for
our champion yeah absolutely Alice
congratulations really fantastic
performance in this tournament great job
on winning this title my question is you
know a lot of people have a lot of hopes
for you right you are winning this
tournament so young you are just 13
years old and this tournament is for
girls under the age of 20. so big
achievement but you already played
really well in the American Cup in the
U.S Championship you also have the
international Master title your imelect
so I'm wondering there could be a lot of
pressure on you how people say you know
the Great American talent how do you
handle that yeah that's a good question
so firstly like I try to set my own like
before like people who are saying like I
should become a great math in the next
two years or something I just started
like my own goal which is to uh just
like improve and
um generally I try like not to focus on
what people are saying and there is some
pressure involved
um but mostly just like focusing on it
is more helpful than like going under
the pressure to become really good
because again I think the less pressure
I have on myself the better I'll be able
to perform
absolutely and Alice I just want to say
that I had predicted that you were going
to win I couldn't I didn't ask Kate to
join me but I couldn't convince
Christian Christian
that's the truth don't throw me under
the bus yes sir I see what you're doing
there uh congratulations Alice really a
dream come true for you and uh well
we're all proud of you well done thank
you absolutely as here we have fear that
Master Alice Lee the 2023 U.S junior
girls Champion again fantastic
performance fantastic year of chess for
her and she wins six thousand dollars as
well as a ten thousand dollar uh
scholarship to any University of her
choice and the tickets to the U.S
women's championships absolutely
and